[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا مشاهدينا الكرام مستمرون معكم اذا في
متابعتي نتائج الفرز للانتخابات الرئاسيه
التركيه وكذلك البرلمانيه التي اجريت
اليوم اذن اردوغان يتراجع عن الخمسين
بالمئه بعد احصاء
88.59
من الاصوات هذا اخر تحديث نقلا عن
هذا المصدر
يتعارض ايضا ارقام هي حرب ارقام ما بين
وكاله الاناضول التي اتهمت بانها تقدم
ارقام تبين تفوق اردوغان وهو الامر الذي
نفته وكاله
الاناضول النتائج الاوليه اذن كما نتابع
على الشاشه 50.01 بالمئه لصالح الرئيس
الحالي المنتهيه ولايه وهرجه بردوغان في
مقابل 44.22 بالمئه لمنافسه كمال كلجدار
اوغلو الممثل لاحزاب المعارضه التركيه
السته طبعا هذه الارقام يمكن ان تت بين
لحظه واخرى بالنظر الى الارقام التي تم
تقديمها كان هناك تقدم واضح
اردوغان
ومرور الى اكثر من 50% بمعنى انه هو بحاجه
الى خمسين
51% على الاقل كي تحسم هذه الانتخابات من
دور واحد الان هذه الارقام اذا تتغير ربما
ما يجعل الاحتماليه الذهاب الى جوله اعاده
ثانيه تجرى بعد 15 يوما ما تزال وارده
ولكن هذا طبعا يعني
رهن بالارقام النهائيه نبقى حذرين نحن
مشاهدينا معكم في استقاء الارقام اولا
باول طبعا هذه تبقى نتائج اوليه والارقام
هي يعني متضاربه حسب كل طرف الجهه التي
تصدر هذه الارقام اذن وكانت الاناضول اذا
الان تقول ان اردوغان يحصل على
49.98 شاهدوا مشاهدينا اذا الارقام
الجديده تبين الان انه اردوغان اقل من
الخمسين
اذا بعد فرز 91% من الاصوات ومنافسه
كالجده روغل باربعه واربعين فاصل 23
[موسيقى]
اذا اما وكاله رويترز اذا فنقلا عن
اردوغان كذلك الرقم يعني ليس بعيد كثيرا
هو عند 50% يعني اردوغان لم يصل الى عتبه
51 بالمئه التي تمكنه من حسم هذه المعركه
هذه الليله يعني هناك مفاجاه قد تحصل هذه
الليله على العموم نبقي اعيننا على مختلف
المصادر التركيه لان ارقامها يمكن ان تغير
شيئا في المعادله حسب الارقام اذا التي
نتابعها معكم على الشاشه ومع شبكه موفدين
ومراسلينا كذلك اذا من انقره فاطمه فهد
اهلا بك من اسطنبول طاهر بركه اهلا بك
وكذلك سيكون معنا من غازي عنتاب
وكذلك من كر مان مارش غسان ابو لوز ومن
هاتاي عبد القادر خربوش مرحبا بكم جميعا
طاهر ابدا معك انت في مقر العداله
والتنميه حزب اردوغان ما الذي يقولونه
هناك
اهلا بك صهيب الكل ينتظر هذه اللحظات
الحاسمه اللحظه بلحظه الكل يعني قلق
ومتوتر لان الارقام قاربت على ان تعرف
بنهايتها ولو انها تتغير تباعا واحيانا
يبقى الرقم مثبتا عند حد معين ولا يتغير
ولكن الارقام التي امامنا على هذه الشاشه
العملاقه في داخل مقر حزب العداله
والتنميه في اسطنبول لا تزال عند 89
بالمئه فاصل اربعه وعشرين
وتعطي للاردغان
49.94 باقل
عن عتبه الخمس نقلا في الخبر تماما تماما
طبعا نعم طبعا هذا صحيح تماما زيدان كان
يقول في بث مباشر سابق لعلكم يعني في
نقلكم المباشر اللاحق معهم تتاكدون منه عن
ان الارقام حتى للصناديق التي فرزت تخطط
التسعين في الواقع ولكن انا يعني التزم
بالذي يعلنه حزب العداله والتنميه رسميا
الذي انا في مقره وعلى شاشاته العملاقه لا
يزال يلتزم
ب89.24
بالمئه ولكن اردوغان بعدما كان متخطيا
خمسين بالمئه لاول مره ارى انه
بخفض يعني اقل من عشر نقطه مئويه ظهر 50
هذا خبر الساعه وهذا تطور صحيح في هذه
الليله اردوغان يتراجع عن الخمسين بالمئه
بعدما كان
ظهر بانه
يتخطى باريحيه حاجز 51 بالمئه هو الامر
الذي شككت فيه المعارضه ومرشحها
وقال انه وكاله الاناضول يعني هي تقدم
ارقام تبين افضليه اردوغان وهو الامر الذي
نفته وكاله الاناضول كذلك فاطمه فهد انت
في انقره الى اين وصلت معركه الارقام عندك
في انقره
حقيقه هي في تقارب كبير جدا وسريع جدا
يعني الان الارقام تشير بان نسبه التصويت
لارج هي 46% فاصله 70 ونسبه التصويت لك
للجدار وصلت الى
46.50 يعني لك ان تتخيل هذا
النسبه المتقاربه بشكل كبير طبعا مجرد ان
نزلت نسبه
اردوغان عن الخمسين نعم بدا بدات او بدا
مناصروا المعارضه هنا بالاحتفالات
والهتافات والغناء ونستطيع ان نسمع
الاغاني في الخارج ايضا خارج مقر حزب
الشعب الجمهوري الذي نتواجد فيه الان
الاحتفالات لحزب مخطط التسعين بالمئه ام
ليس بعد
نعم هي
92.30% بالضبط تحديدا الان في انقره ممتاز
طيب تقارب كبير ايضا في انقره ايضا بين كل
رجب طيب اردوغان اذا المشاهدين نحن امام
تطور متفاعل يتفاعل بين لحظه واخرى معكم
نتائج الانتخابات اذا الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه
لاول مره في هذه الساعه فاطمه لديك اضافه
تفضلي
نعم هناك نقطه مهمه يعني تشير النتائج
الاوليه وكثير من الخبراء بان نسبه فرص
صناديق اصوات الناخبين الاتراك في الخارج
مهمه جدا يعني انباء تقول بان اخر تحديث
هي 16% ما تعادل يعني 176 الف اكثر يعني
ولكن هي من اصل اكثر من مليون ونصف ناخب
صوت وخلال الاقتراع قبل 14 مايو اذا ما
انتم فرز الاصوات نعم المصوطين خارج تركيا
يعني الباقي المليون صوت يعني هذه ستكون
فارقه بالفعل فاطمه طيب نذهب الى غسان ابو
لوز اذا كان جاهز معنا غسان اهلا بك معنا
انت في كهرمان مرعش احدى المناطق الاكثر
تضررا بزلزال تركيا ما الذي ترصده هناك
الان في هذه اللحظات الحاسمه
اجواء احتفاليه صهيب احتفلت مبكرا كهرمان
مرعش يعني تصدر رجب طيب اردوغان بهذه
الولايه يعني نسبه التصويت لرجب طيب
اردوغان في كهرمان مرعش تجاوزت 71% في
مقابل يعني اكثر من عشرين بالمئه
وهو فرق كبير جدا وهذا يعني طبيعي بالنسبه
لولايه كهرمان مرعش وهي ولايه لطالما كانت
تصوت للرئيس اردوغان وحزب العداله
والتنميه في الانتخابات السابقه وطيله
السنوات الماضيه وبالتالي هي محسوبه على
حزب العداله والتنميه والرئيس اردوغان
هناك احتفالات متواصله حتى هذه الساعه
روما تقلص الفارق بين اردوغان وبينك
الجدار اوغلو الا انهم ما زالوا يحتفلون
حتى هذه الساعه وحتى هذه اللحظه عمليه
التصويت اجمالا في عموم فرز عمليات الفرز
في اجمالي البلاد لم تنتهي حتى هذه اللحظه
وهم متمسكون بالامل خلال الساعات المقبله
لكنهم يقولون ايضا ان ذهبت الانتخابات الى
جوله ثانيه فهذا لا يهم هم على موقفهم على
موقفهم وسيقومون بالتصويت لاردوغان مره
اخرى في 28 شهر يعني لم يكن يعني كيف يفسر
هذا الموقف بالذهاب باتجاه اردوغان بالرغم
من الانتقادات التي طالت السلطات فيما
يتعلق بالتكفل
بضحايا الزلزال غسان
[موسيقى]
نعم بالفعل صهيب وهو هذا ما رهنت عليه
المعارضه الاشهر الماضيه وهو الوتر الذي
حاولت ان تلعب عليه طيله الاشهر الماضيه
وتحاول ان تقلب هؤلاء خصوصا في كهرمان
مرعش والولايات الجنوبيه هناك تسع ولايات
اخرى تاريخيا هي مواليه للرئيس اردوغان
وحزب العداله والتنميه وكانت المعرض تحاول
ان تحدث شرقا بين هؤلاء
لكن الارقام كما نتحدث عن اكثر من 71%
لاردوغان تثبت عكس ذلك وغير ذلك هم
يعتبرون ما جرى من كارثه هي كارثه طبيعيه
الحكومه لا يدفي فيها وبالتالي
الحكومه والرئيس قاموا بنا بوسعهم وقدموا
جميع ما يمكن ان يقدمه خلال هذه الكارثه
نعم
نذهب الى هاتاي احدى مناطق الزلزال كذلك
عبد القادر خربوش معنا من هناك ما الذي
ترصده هناك عبد القادر ايضا ليس جاهز معنا
ربما سنعود اليه بعد قليل اعود الى طاهر
بركه في اسطنبول طاهر رئيس بلديه اسطنبول
المعارضه اكرم الماموخلو
الذي قد يعين نائبا للرئيس اذا فاز كي
الجدار اغلب الرئاسه طلب من المواطنين عدم
تصديق الارقام التي تقدمها وكاله الاناضول
التركيه
برايك هل يعني الفارق هل هناك فارق كبير
في الارقام التي تقدمها وكاله الانباء
الاخرى التابعه للمعارضه او المؤيده
للمعارضه دعنا نقول
تقول المعارضه ان الارقام التي لديها
مغايره لتلك التي تقدمها وكاله الاناضول
للانباء ولكن هذه الوكاله ردت على اتهامات
اكرم امام اوغلو وعلى اتهامات الطرف الاخر
المعارض وقالت نرفض جميع انواع الاتهامات
والادعاءات التي لا اساس لها ضد شركتنا
ونعلن اننا سنستخدم حقوقنا القانونيه على
اكمل وجه ضد جميع الاتهامات والادعاءات
التي تحتوي على معلومات مضلله طبعا نائب
رئيس حزب العداله والتنميه كان قال ايضا
نحن متقدمون في الانتخابات البرلمانيه
والرئاسيه وانهم يلومون المؤسسات بسبب
الذعر الذي حدث لهم يعيب على الطرف
المعارض اذا وفي الوقت الحالي نحن متقدمون
بفارق كبير كانت هذه التصريحات قبل ان
تتحدث الارقام في الفتره الاخيره التي
تحدثنا عنها اخر الارقام كانت وصلت اخر
رقم وصلني للفرز كان منذ قليل واحدا
اما على شاشه مقر حزب العداله والتنميه
فلا تزال عند
89.24 بالمئه المصدر هو نفسه من تي ار تي
هبر كاب لقناه تي ار تي خبر ولكن
فيما يتعلق بالشاشه التي امامنا لا تزال
عند
89.24 اما على التطبيق تطبيق هذه القناه
فالنسب تختلف وتجاوزت التسعين بالمئه منذ
يعني قليله ولكن الارقام حتى الان عند
49.94
للرئيس اردوغان مقابل
44.30 بالمئه
نعم نعم اذا
49.94% لصالح اردوغان 44.30 بالمئه
مرشح المعارضه التركيه
الرئيس الفائز بحاجه الى اكثر من خمسين
بالمئه لحسم هذه المعركه اذهب اليك فاطمه
في انقره من الامور التي يتوقف عندها
المتابع في هذه الانتخابات التركيه
حجم
المشاركه الكبير جدا في هذه الانتخابات ما
الذي رصدتيه من يعني اقبال من الاتراك على
هذه الانتخابات وهل لدينا ارقام عن نسب
المشاركه النهائيه
نعم صهيب الاقبال كان كبير جدا يعني بحسب
الخبراء المتواجدون هنا حولنا نتحدث اليهم
جميعا وقالوا انه بالفعل يعني كانت نسب
الاقبال على الكل على الاقل في مراكز
الاقتراع التي قمنا بزيارتها هذا الصباح
[موسيقى]
باسم حزب العداله والتنميه اجلي الحفاظ
على
الاجواء الامنيه
السليمه للانتخابات
الان جميع
العاملين في مجال فرز الاصوات
والاحصاء وممثل الاحزاب بالاضافه الى
ممثلي الوكالات
الاخباريه
والاعلاميه لانهم الان يمارسون دورهم
سيكون هنالك تقييم كامل بعد
انهاء جميع
الاجراءات من هذه
الشاشه اشكر جميع
المساهمين في هذه في هذا العرس الديمقراطي
قبل قليل ايضا نوهتوا الى نقطه هامه وهي
قيام
السيد رئيس بلديه اسطنبول ورئيس بلديه
انقره اعلنوا
بعد فتره قليله من اغلاق
الصناديق باعلانهم عن
ان السيد كمال كلشتار ورئيس للجمهوريه
التركيه اعتقد بانها لم تكن محدى صدفه
وانما كان مخططا مدروسا
يستهدفون هذه
التجربه الديمقراطيه
وما زلت الساعات الاولى في فرز
الاصوات لم يحترموا الادمقراطيه لم
يحترموا الاراده الوطنيه لم يحترموا
الاحزاب
السياسيه
باستخدامهم لهذه
الالفاظ وبما انهم قاموا بعد وقت قليل من
اغلاق الصناديق كان لهم ان يظهروا مره
اخرى وان يعتذروا من جميع المواطنين ولكن
على العكس تماما لم يظهروا
الى الان هنالك فرق كبير بين
مرشحي اتفاقي والتحالف الشعب
وممثله وممثل التحالف
امه هذا
بالاضافه الى فرق كبير ايضا في
الانتخابات
البرلمانيه دائما
كعادتنا نحن نحترم كما احترمنا في الماضي
نتائج جميع الانتخابات ومره اخرى حزب
الشعب الجمهوري
كعادته لم يحترم
ويمارس دوره كما كان في الانتخابات
الماضيه اقول بان جميع هذا السلوك
والتصرفات وعدم احترام
للاراده الوطنيه عدم احترام للانتخابات
وجميع اجراءاتها من الباب الى محراب
اعتقد بانهم يمارسون الدور
التالي استهدفوا الاعداد والارقام
والاحصاءات الصادره عن وكاله الاناضول
نحن
دائما
نؤيد
الديمقراطيه لجميع الاحزاب ان قاموا
باجراءات
ديمقراطيه ودائما
ننوه الى حق
جميع الاحزابات السياسيه وحقوق
السياسيين عندما
لا يثقون بارقام واحصائيات صادره من وكاله
اخباريه
واعلاميه ولكن عندما تظهر في نفس الوقت
الذي الذي تستهدف فيه وكالات
تعلن عن بعض
وكالات او بعض المؤسسات التابعه لك وتعلن
بان هذه المعلومات والاحصائيات هي الصحيحه
اعتقد بان هذه التصرفات وعدم احترام
لتجربه
الديمقراطيه وعدم احترام
للسياسه بل هو ابتزاز لكل ما
يقوم به الاخرون باجراءات
ديمقراطيه في هذه الانتخابات
لا ربما كان هنالك بعض استطلاعات الراي
التابعه او المؤيده لبعض الاحزاب التي
كانت تعطي لنفسها او لحزبها ارقام كبيره
وتعطي لنفسها الفوز في الانتخابات
قبل قبل حتى حصول هذه الانتخابات
وان احد هذه الاجراءات ايضا هو ظهور رئيس
بلديتي اسطنبول وانقره
بان الزعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري هو الاول
واظهار بان السيد رجب طيب باردوان ياتي
بفارق كبير قبل
انهاء العد الاخير
للانتخابات واعتقد بانها اجراءات
تستهدف هذه الاراده الوطنيه وهو عدم
احترام
للاراده
الوطنيه اعتقد بان هذه الاجراءات تاتي من
اجل تشكيل وبناء بنيه تحتيه للاجراءات
المقبله
لهؤلاء وبالتالي خلق اجواء التوتر
والقلق
وقبل الانتخابات بيوم او ليله طلبه من
جميع المواطنين عدم
خروج الى الشوارع والازقه
والميادين اعتقد به ان هذا اليوم اليوم
الانتخابات
كان يوما امنا جميع المواطنين مارسوا حقهم
الطبيعي وان عقليه وذهنيه حسب الشعب
الجمهوري كما كانت في الماضي الان
تتجسد مره اخرى بالقيام بهذه الاجراءات
كاسياسيين وكاحزاب سياسيه نحن نقول
بان الواجبات والمهام الملقاه على عاتقنا
هو تجسيد الاراده الوطنيه
والاستماع الى
افكارهم
التوجه اليهم اثناء القيام بالحمله
الانتخابيه ودائما كنا نقول بان الاراده
الوطنيه
ستتجسد في يوم الانتخاب
وسنحترم نتائج الانتخابات في جميع حملاتنا
الانتخابيه
ركزنا على هذه الجمل
والمصطلحات الهامه اما حزب الشعب الاجمه
الجمهوري فاهمل
جميع الاجراءات القانونيه
والاجراءات
الديمقراطيه لما يقوم به جميع
الكوادر نحن نعتبر الاراده الوطنيه واراده
الشعب تاج على رؤوسنا وهو اي المواطن هو
صاحب الحق الوحيد في اختيار رئيسي دولته
واعضاء برلمانه ولا يمكن لاي احد
الخروج والحديث باسم زعماء
ايضا الكرام نحن نستمع معكم الى عمر
جليليك المتحدث باسم الحزب الحاكم حزب
العداله والتنميه حزب الرئيس الحاليه
منتهي ولايته رجب طيب اردوغان الذي يتراجع
بتصحيح باعشار فقط ولكن ينزل عن ع تبه
الخمسين بالمئه ما يجعل احتماليه ان يتم
الذهاب الى جوله اعاده انتخابات رئاسيه في
جوله ثانيه بينه وبين كلجدار اوغلو بعد 15
يوما حسب الدستور التركي ولكن وهذا طبعا
بعد فرز
90.61 بالمئه من الاصوات حتى الان طيب
معنى فاطمه اذا ما تزال معنا فاطمه من
انقره
فاطمه انت معي
طيب
كنا نتحدث عن نسبه الاقبال الكبيره في هذه
الانتخابات
نعم فعلا رصدنا نسبه قبال كبيره جدا في
مراكز الاختراع التي زرناها منذ هذا
الصباح وكان اهم تلك المراكز هو مركز
الاختراع المتواجد في مدرسه ارجنتين
الابتدائيه وهي المدرسه التي تخرج منها
اكليجار اوغلو وهي ذات المدرسه التي اتى
اليها وصوت فيها وكنا هناك لنرصد ذلك طبعا
واهميتها ايضا تكمن في المكان الذي تقع
فيه المنطقه التي تقع فيه كما ذكر سابقا
هي منطقه مؤيده بشكل كبير للمعارضه
بالتالي اغالبيه المتواجدون هناك في تلك
او في تلك المنطقه في ذلك المركز تحديدا
كانت اصواتهم لصالح كليج دار اوغلو على
عكس الحي القريب من تلك المنطقه
والذي يوجد فيها من مؤيدون
للاردغان اكثر من كريشدار وغالبيه الاصوات
في الحي القريب منه لصالح اردوغان الان
الاناضول تشير بان النسب
التصويت لاردوغان في انخ مستمر اكل جدار
اوغلو 49% لاردوغان و44% لك
تشير بان اردوغان يواصل التراجع ويحصل على
49.86% من الاصوات ما يعني بشكل حتمي على
ما يبدو الانتقال الى جوله ثانيه صهيب
اذهب الى طاهر بركه طاهر انت في مقر حزب
العداله والتنميه ومتابعه ايضا لارقام
وكاله الاناضول وكما كنا نتابع المتحدث
باسم العداله والتنميه يعني شن هجوما على
المعارضه على رئيسي بلديه اسطنبول وانقره
وقال بان الامر مخطط له بتقديم ارقام
خاطئه تشير الى فوز
هذا صحيح وبثينا على شاشاتنا معظم ما قاله
هو انتهى للتو قبل قليل وكانت اتهمه هذه
الاطراف تحديدا وقال انها عقليه حزب الشعب
الجمهوري لطالما كانت حزب الشعب الجمهوري
عقليته هكذا اي عقليه التي يتحدث بها اكرم
امام اوغلو ومنصور يواش طبعا نحن يعني
استمعنا الى الكثير من الاتهامات القاسيه
فيما يتعلق بعدم احترام الديمقراطيه
الاتهام حزب العداله والتنميه للطرف الاخر
اي حزب الشعب الجمهوري ويقولون ويرددون
دائما على لسان مسئوليهم ان الديمقراطيه
هي تاج رؤوسنا ويوم الرابع عشر من مايو هو
يوم الديمقراطيه ويجب ان نحترم هذا قرار
الشعب وقرار الناس وهو الذي اوصلنا الى
السلطه وهو الذي نسلم من خلاله السلطه ان
لم يختارون الان يعيبون على الطرف الاخر
انه لم ينتظر نتائج الانتخابات وكانه لم
يعترف بالنتائج التي
النتائج العامه للانتخابات الرئاسيه حتى
الان وفقا لما هو امامي في المقر
90.61 بالمئه
اردوغان منهم
49.86 مقابل
44.88 بالمئه اما
بخصوصيه
ايضا طاهر نحن نحدث كذلك الارقام اولا
باول على الشاشه
وبانتظار المزيد معك طبعا ومع الزملاء
دعني فقط اذهب الى كرمان مرعش وغسان ابو
لوز مره اخرى غسان قبل قليل الرصدت لنا
بدايه احتفالات جمهور اردوغان في كرمان
مرعش هل تراجع ارقامه الان في هذه الاثناء
هل يعني جعل جماهير العداله والتنميه ربما
تتراجع او تتريث قليلا في انتظار النتائج
النهائيه
[موسيقى]
هو في الحقيقه صهيب ليس قبل قليل بدات
الاحتفالات الاحتفالات بدات مبكرا يعني
بعد ساعه تقريبا من اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع
وبدء عمليه فرز الاصوات بدات الاحتفالات
في الشوارع لغايه الان ما زالت مواكب
السيارات والمواكب الاحتفاليه تجوب شوارع
مدينه كهرمان مرعش ونحن نشاهد في هذا
الشارع على امتداد هذا الشارع بهذا
الاتجاه خلف الكاميرا يقع مقر حزب العداله
والتنميه وبالتالي كل السيارات بهذا
الاتجاه وهناك ايضا مواطنين مروا من هنا
وقالوا لنا بان هناك احتفاليه كبيره ستتم
بعد ساعه من الان هم لغايه الان ما زالوا
يحتفلون والاعداد بالعكس تتزايد
صهيب في هذه النسبه على الاقل في كهرمان
مرعش وهي نسبه عاليه جدا
للرئيس اردوغان ويحتفلون بهذه النسبه على
انها فوز لهذه الولايه بالنسبه
ولايه كهرمان مرعش وهي كما ذكرنا انها
تاريخيا تميل الى اردوغان وبالتالي هم
مستمرون
الى جوله ثانيه
عليها صوره كبيره لاردوغان رغم طبعا تراجع
ارقامه وتراجع يعني الاصوات التي حصل
عليها عن عتبه الخمسين بالمئه ما يفتح
ربما التكهنات بامكانيه الذهاب الى جوله
ثانيه من هذه الانتخابات سنرى على العموم
على مدار هذه الليله نحن نتابع النتائج
اولا باول نتيجه الفرز حتى الان
90.61% من صناديق الاقتراع ارحب بضيفي في
هذه الساعه مهند حافظ اوغلو من اسطنبول
وهو الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي الدكتور
مهند اهلا بك معنا فرز اكثر من 90% من
الاصوات واردوغان يتراجع عن عتبه الخمسين
بالمئه هل نحن ذاهبون الى جوله اعاده بعد
15 يوما
مساء صهيب وجميع المشاهدين بالفعل هكذا
تبدو الامور تفسير نحو جوله الاعاده
الجميل واللافت في الامر بان هذا التنافس
الديمقراطي الشفاف والشريف
تتمثل به وتلبسه تركيا في هذا اليوم
الجميل بان الانتخابات على قدم وساق
والتنافس على اشدهم وهذه الديمقراطيه
الارقام بين الرئيس اردوغان وكمان ليست
بالكبيره جدا هذا دليل على هذا الاستقطاب
الحادي اولا وعلى صعوبه هذه الانتخابات
ولكن طبعا يعاب على كما تحدث المتحدث باسم
حسب العداله والتنميه بالفعل يعني
هذا التصريح على المباغت المفاجئ
وسبق الاحداث قبل ان تنتهي وبالتالي يعني
هذا الامر ليس
لا يتناسب ولا يتلازم ولا يتناسق مع
تصريحات كمال كريستال اوغلوم بان
الديمقراطيه اشتاقت ان التركيه اشتاقت
للديمقراطيه وان تركيا اشتاقت للحريه طيب
لماذا هذا الاستعجال في هذه التصريحات
يعني لماذا هذا هل هذه تصريحات هي تعبر عن
قلقانه
ولكن ردا على هذا كان انا استمعت الى احد
المؤيدين للمعارضه وهو يقول انه العداله
والتنميه يحاول ان يسوق في بدايه الفرز
انه يعني متصدر حتى يكسر معنويات الطرف
الاخر
يا سيدي المعنويات هنا ليست بذات اولويه
اليوم الصندوق هو الحكم سواء كانت معنويات
الداعمين لاردوغان عاليه او منخفضه حزينه
او سعيده او العكس لدى كم هذا في النهايه
شعور نفسي الحكم هو لصندوق الاقتراع
وبالتالي يجب التصريحات ان تكون منضبطه من
اي مسؤول في هذه الطاوله السداسيه ولا
تخرج تصريحات لا تتوافق مع قانون
الانتخابات ولا مع اللجنه العليا
للانتخابات وهذا عذرا على المقاطعه نشير
فقط الى العاجل الاناضول ايضا تشير الى
تقدم اذا كل جدار اغلو في انقره في
العاصمه التركيه اذهب الان الى ضيفه ايضا
باسل حجاسم الباحث والمحلل السياسي ينضم
الينا من انقره دكتور باسل اهلا بك معنا
هل تعتقد ان الانتخابات التركيه لن تحسم
الليله واننا ذاهبون الى جوله اعاده
مساء الخير لك وللمشاهدين الكرام في
الواقع قد يكون ضروري علينا انتظار نهايه
فرس كل الاصوات خصوصا انه حتى الان هناك
نسبه قليله لا تتجاوز 15% من اصوات اتراك
الخارج وهم
يمتلكون نسبه لا يستهان بها ويمكنها ان
تقلب الموازين خصوصا ان النسبه التي
يحتاجها
مرشح تحالف الشعب او جمهور رجب طيب
اردوغان الرئيس الحالي لتجاوز عتبه
الخمسين هي ضئيله جدا لذلك لابد من انتظار
ربما ساعات قليله ليكون القرار النهائي هل
ستكون هناك جوله ثانيه ام هذه الجوله
ستحسم الامور ويفوز بها طيب اردوغان لان
كمالك الازدهار عقله يحتاج الكثير وابات
مؤكد انه لن يتمكن من الحسم في الجوله
الاولى بينما رجب طيب اردوغان فرصه امامه
للحسم بعد فرز كل اصوات اتراك الخارج
ومعروف دوما ان اتراك الخارج النسبه
الاكبر منهم تاتي اصواتها لصالح رجب طيب
اردوغان لذلك اعتقد من المبكر الحكم ان
اننا ذاهبون بخصوص انتخابات الرئاسه الى
جوله ثانيه نعم طيب اذا مشاهدينا عوده الى
تحديث الارقام اذن معكم الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان اذا بعد ان كان قد تخطى عتبه
الخمسين بالمئه بعد فرز 90% من الاصوات هو
يتراجع اقل بقليل من عتبه هذه الخمسين
بالمئه هو بحاجه الى اكثر من ذلك حتى يتم
حسم الفوز بهذه الانتخابات الرئاسيه طبعا
في انتظار كذلك
فرز اصوات الجاليه التركيه في الخارج
وطبعا هي اصواتها وازنه هناك اخر تحديث
تحدث كما ذكرت موفدتنا جرى فرس 17 بالمئه
فقط من اصوات الاتراك في الخارج
وهناك يعني يفوق العدد المليون صوت
وبالتالي هناك ارقام اخرى قد تغير هذه
المعادله اذا نتابع اذا في التحديثات عند
49 بالمئه اذا رئيس رجب طيب اردوغان الان
بعد فرز تسعين بالمئه من الاصوات مقابل
44.38 بالمئه لكل جدار اوغلو دكتور مهند
اعود اليك واسالك كذلك هل بحد ذاتها
الارقام هذه الاربعه والاربعين بالمئه
لكلش في مقابل 49% لاردوغان هل تشكل
مفاجاه ام هذا متوقع
لا هذا متوقع بالفعل يعني الحشد الكبير
الطاوله السداسيه بتنوع مشاربها تحالفات
الضروره التي جرت ما بين القوميين وما بين
العلمانيين في هذه الطاوله السداسيه
توصيه الرؤساء الاحزاب لقواعدهم من الشعب
بان يصوتوا لكم
هذه العوامل كلها كانت تؤشر الى ان
الاحتدام سوف يكون كبير يعني كلنا يتوقع
كاننا سوف يحصل على الاربعين وما فوق هذا
بشكل تلقائي وطبيعي المنافسه شديده وحاده
ولكن الجميل ايضا بان هناك ليس تقاربا
كبيرا ما بينهما هناك نحن نتكلم عن حوالي
خمسه الى سته
نقاط او 6% من النقاط وبالتالي هذا فارق
حقيقي وكبير يتفوق به الرئيس اردوغان
وربما هذا يؤدي الى مؤشر بان غالبيه الشعب
او يعني ترجح او ترجح كافه الرئيس على
منافسه طبعا ترجيح كافه اردوغان اذا ما
حصلت سوف لا تكون لها اسباب عديده وكثيره
ليس اولها محاوله الرئيس اردوغان تبقى
تركيا مستقله ولن يكون اخرها تلك الوعود
بمستقبل مشرق نعم
يبدو ان هناك الان مؤتمرا صحفيا اذا
لاكرم امامو وهو عمده اسطنبول طبعا وهو
متحالف مع
المترشح عن المعارضه كمال المنافس القوي
لاردوغان والذي قد يصبح اذن نائبا للرئيس
اذا ما فاز كلجدار اوغلو بالرئاسه طبعا
للانتفاق
للمعارضه لا اعلم اذا كنا سنستمع الى اكرم
امام مغلو
ليس لدينا ايضا على العموم سنك اعيننا على
التصريحات التي يدلي بها الى الممثل
المعارضه التركيه قبل قليل كنا استمعنا
الى عمر جليلك المتحدث باسم الحزب الحاكم
حزب العداله والتنميه حزب اردوغان واتهم
رئيس بلديه اسطنبول ورئيس بلديه انقره بان
لديهما مخطط
للتشويش على الديمقراطيه التركيه
باعلانهما
بان كل جدار اوغلو قد فاز على اردوغان
وبان ان يجب عليهم ان يعتذروا للمواطنين
الاتراك كما قال المتحدث باسم الحزب
الحاكم حزب العداله والتنميه اذا مشاهدينا
معكم في متابعه خبر الساعه لهذه الليله
نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه
والبرلمانيه كذلك التي تجرى بالتزامن حتى
الان الرئيس اردوغان بعد فرز اكثر من 90%
من الاصوات هو عند عتبه الخمسين بالمئه
بقليل هو اقل منها ولكن هو بحاجه ان
يتجاوز عت بالمئه حتى يضمن الفوز بالرئاسه
وعدم الذهاب الى جوله اعاده جوله ثانيه
بعد 15 يوما منافسه مرشح المعارضه الاحزاب
المعارضه السته للرئيس اردوغان كمال كلش
دار اوغلو عند
44,88 بالمئه ونسبه الفرز كما تشاهدون
90.61
بالمئه اعود اليك دكتور باسل الحاج جاسم
واسالك يعني
كان هناك حديث على انه اصوات الاتراك في
الخارج لم تفرز بعد بالكامل متى يمكن
القول انها يمكن ان تحسم هذا التقارب او
يعني هذه المنافسه الشديده بين اردوغان
وكل
المفترض انها الليله يعني هي بالتوازي مع
فرز اصوات الداخل
يفترض انه جاري ايضا الفرز بعد ساعات
قليله يفترض ان تعلن النتائج الاوليه
لجميع الاصوات اصوات الداخل واصوات الخارج
ودوما يعني ينظر لهذا الصوت صوت اتراك
الخارج بانه مرتبط
بعوامل تتعلق خصوصا بالسياسه الخارجيه
التركيه عوامل اخرى كثيره مثل الاقتصاد لا
تؤثر على صوت الناخب التركي في الخارج هو
لا يتاثر لا بالتضخم الذي تشهده تركيا ولا
بموضوع ارتفاع الاسعار او تراجع الليره
لذلك قلت انا في بدايه حديثي ان في الغالب
كانت اصواتهم تصب في صالح مرشح تعالف
الشعب او الجمهور الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب
اردوغان لذلك انتظار فرز كامل
لمعظم اصوات اطراف الخارج هو
دكتور دكتور باسل اعذرني على المقاطعه فقط
خبر عاجل اخر اردوغان يواصل التراجع عن
عتبه الخمسين بالمئه بعد 49.8 الان ينزل
الى 49.76
بالمئه مقابل
44.48 بالمئه لكل جدار اوغلو نسبه الفرز
وصلت الى 92 بالمئه اذا بالفعل يبدو اننا
امام مفاجاه ربما قد تقلب موازين توقعات
الانتخابات في تركيا ربما سنكون امام جوله
اعاده بالنظر الى ان حسب الدستور التركي
او قانون الانتخابات التركي فان المرشح
الذي لا يحصل على اكثر من خمسين بالمئه في
هذه الحاله يتم الذهاب الى جوله اعاده في
البدايه في بدايه الفرد كانت الارقام تشير
الى تقدم واضح لاردوغان وصل الى اكثر من
51 بالمئه عبد القادر خربوش اذا يجهز معنا
الان مباشره من
غزي عنتاب عذرا اذا عبد القادر اهلا بك
معنا الصوره من عندك ما الذي ترصده الان
في هذه اللحظات في ظل هذه اللحظات الحاسمه
وتقارب الارقام
[موسيقى]
فعلا صهيب انا بغازي عنتاب وتفاجئ وصولي
بهاته موجات الفرحه
انصار انصار عبد القادر من فضلك
هلق قربت المايكروفون الى فمك اكثر لاننا
لا نتمكن من السماء اليك بسبب الضوضاء
[موسيقى]
القادر
عبد القادر هل تسمعني
عبد القادر
سعيد جدا من فضلك قرب الميكروفون حتى
نتمكن من السماء استماع اليك بوضوح في ظل
هذه الاهازيج العاليه
نعم صهيب مثل ما قلت هناك احتفالات عارمه
هنا بغازي عنتاب
مثلما تشاهد في هذه الصور المباشره انصار
حزب
عداله والتنميه هنا بغازي عنتاب يحتفلون
بهذا
النتيجه التي حققها حزبهم
رجب طيب
النتائج خصوصا هنا في غازي عنتاب
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
عبد القادر يعني
اصواته الاهازيج والاحتفالات تعلو فوق
صوتك ولكن على العموم نحن ننقل هذه الصوره
ونتابع اذا هذه الاحتفالات المبكره من
غازي عنتاب من جمهور الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان وطبعا حز به الحزب الحاكم حزب
العداله والتنميه في غاز عنتاب رغم ان
المعركه لم تحسم بعد يعني كانت الارقام
صحيح في البدايه تشير الى تقدم اردوغان
ب51 بالمئه هو الان يتراجع مع استمرار
تقدم الفرز لا نعلم اذا كان يعني هؤلاء
المحتفلين ربما
سيخيب املهم في النهايه ام لا ام بالفعل
هم استبقوا الفوز بهذه الاحتفالات المبكره
الصوره مباشره من غازي عنتاب
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا هذه الصور المباشره
لاحتفالات جماهير حزب العداله والتنميه
حزب الرئيس الحاكم رجب طيب اردوغان
المنتهيه ولايتها رغم ان المعركه لم تحسم
بعد هناك ارقام جديده مع استمرار الفرز
ووصوله الى 92% من الفرز اردوغان تراجع عن
عتبه الخمسين بالمئه هو عند 49.76 بالمئه
الامر الذي يمكن ان يؤدي الى الذهاب الى
جوله اعاده ثانيه في هذه الاثناء مشاهدينا
عمده اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو الان يتحدث
وهو يقول انه يوجد 7.5 مليون صوت لصالح
المعارضه لم يتم تسجيلها بعد بمعنى هو
يتنبا بانه يمكن ان تكون هناك مفاجاه وعكس
للارقام اذا عمده اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو
ايضا يقول ان الاتراك سيشاهدون كمال
كلجدار اوغلو رئيسا في الصباح اذا
مشاهدينا المتحدث عن المعارضه التركيه
الذي تشاهدونه هنا على الشاشه بربطه عنق
زرقاء هو اكرم امام اوغلو عمده اسطنبول
والى جانبه عمده
انقره العاصمه انقر طبعا يتحدثان اذا عن
المعارضه التركيه تحالف المعارضه او اصطلح
عليه بتسميه الطاوله الطاوله السداسيه او
طاوله السته من سته احزاب معارضه دعمت
المترشح كما الكل جدار اغلو في منافسه اذن
الرئيس المنتهي ولايته رجب طيب اردوغان
الذي حكم البلاد لعشرين عاما هو يقول اذا
ان الاتراك سيشاهدون كمال كلجد رئيسا في
الصباح هو يتحدث عن 7.5 مليون صوت لم يتم
احتسابها كما يقول مشاهدينا نظره على
الارقام طبعا الارقام الرسميه التي تنقلها
وكاله الاناضول والاعلام
التركي
49.76 بالمئه لاردوغان و44.49 بالمئه لكمل
نسبه فرز الاصوات حتى الان هي 92
بالمئه باقيه ثمانيه بالمئه فقط من
الاصوات لم تفرز بعد اردوغان كان
يعني سجل ارقاما في البدايه الفرز ارقام
مريحه نسبيا امام كلجدار اوغلو كان قد
تجاوز عتبه 51 في المئه وبالتالي كان ضمن
عدم الذهاب الى جوله ثانيه ولكن قبل ان
تنعكس الارقام ويتراجع عن عتبه الخمسين
بالمئه من الاصوات في بدايه هذه الساعه
يعني حتى الان كل ما تقدم الفرز هو يتراجع
صحيح يعني بعشر او باعشار من النقطه
المئويه فقط ولكن هذا يبقى ولو اقل من
الخمسين بالمئه في الاثناء طبعا جماهير
رجب طيب اردوغان وحزب العداله
استبقت النتائج النهائيه وخرجت للاحتفال
في مناطق عده في تركيا خاصه في المناطق
التي تضررت من الزلزال للمناطق الجنوبيه
كما رصدنا قبل قليل مع
زميلنا عبد القادر خربوش من غازي عنتاب
ونشاهد الصوره كذلك في كرمان مرعش المنطقه
الاكثر تضررا بالزلزال من المناطق الاكثر
تضررا الى ايضا هم يحتفلون ولكن المعركه
لم تحسم بعد عمده اسطنبول اكرمه يقول ان
الاتراك
سيجدون كمالك الجدار اوغلو رئيسا في
الصباح ويؤكد انه هناك سبعه فاصل خمسه
مليون صوت لصالح المعارضه لم يتم تسجيلها
بعد اعود اذكر بان نسبه
الاصوات التي تم فرزها حتى الان هي 92
بالمئه من الاصوات دكتور مهند حافظ اوغلو
تركيا يعني الجمهوريه التركيه تقفل قرنها
الاول في دكتور مهند ليس معنا دكتور باسل
دكتور باسل معنا طيب دكتور باسل وحاول
السؤال لك الجمهوريه التركيه اذن تقفل
قرنها الاول هل نحن الان امام منعرج
تاريخي وما شكله يا ترى
نعم بالتاكيد ايا كان الفائز في هذه
الانتخابات
الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه في تركيا امام مرحله جديده
يمكن
تسميه هذا الاستحقاق بانه استفتاء استفتاء
على مستقبل البلاد ليس فقط من سيحكم وانما
الطريقه التي سيحكم بها معروف ان هناك
خطابين او كنا امام خطابين خطاب مثله
ومرشح تحالف الجمهور او الشعب الرئيس
الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان تحدث عن عذرا
دكتور باسل فقط اسمح لي اعطي الان يعني
نشاهد على شاشه العربيه طبعا الارقام نقلا
عن الوكاله الرسميه وكاله الاناضول
التركيه ولكن عمده انقره يقول ان كلجدار
اوغلو حصل على 47%
47.7% حتى الان اما اردوغان فحصل على 45.8
بالمئه حتى الان طبعا حسب عمده انقره طبعا
وهو من المعارضه التركيه
ضد اردوغان دكتور باسل ما رايك في هذه
الارقام التي تقدمها المعارضه
في الواقع نحن كمتابعين او مراقبين لا
يمكننا الاستناد الى اي ارقام سوى الارقام
التي تصدر عن الهيئه العليا او المجلس
الاعلى للانتخابات وهو حتى الان لم يصدر
ارقام رسميه يمكن الاعتماد عليها بالتالي
كل هذه الارقام تبقى في اطار يعني كل طرف
يحاول تعزيز موقعه تماما كما كانت
الاستطلاعات قبل ايام من الانتخابات راينا
الكثير من الاستطلاعات كانت تشير لتفوق
ولو بارقام بسيطه لمرشح المعارضه ايضا كان
هناك بعض دكتور باسل
منصور ياباش هو عمده انقره المعارض طبعا
الذي كان يتحدث كما شاهدناه الى جانب اكرم
امام مغلو عمده اسطنبول وهم معارضه طبعا
للرئيس اردوغان يقول انه من المرجح للغايه
الذهاب الى جوله اعاده في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه وهذا ما نتحدث عنه منذ بدايه
الساعه بالنظر الى
مراقبه الارقام التي يتراجع فيها اردوغان
عن عتبه الخمسين بالمئه كل ما تقدم الفرز
برايك لو حصل هذا السيناريو لو حصل ما
يتحدث عنه عمده انقره منصور يافاش ما
السيناريوهات المحتمله برايك لو ذهبنا الى
جوله اعاده
قبل ذلك اود الاشاره ان فرز اصوات اتراك
الخارج حتى الان تجاوز 20%
وهناك التقدم لاردوغان بالنسبه للاصوات في
المانيا في الدول العربيه المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الكويت مصر بينما يتقدم مرشح
المعارضه في اسواق اتراك الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه كندا النرويج حتى الان حوالي
عشرين بالمئه لاحقا لا نعرف كيف ستكون لكن
خلال ساعه سيتم الفرز بالتاكيد عندما نصل
الى جوله ثانيه سنكون امام العديد من
السيناريوهات لكن سيكون الرقم الصعب فيها
او سيحدد الرابع هو المرشح الثالث
اوغان الذي حصل حتى الان على اكثر من 5%
من الاصوات عندها
التوافق ما هو سيكون هو العامل الاساسي
لتحديد الرابح في الجوله الثانيه وهو
قالها بصراحه قبل عده ايام انه اذا وصلنا
لجوله ثانيه فسيكون جاهز للاتفاق او عقد
صفقمه مقابل مناصب وزاريه او حتى منصب
نائب للرئيس بالتالي
السيناريو الابرز في حال وصلنا الى جوله
ثانيه سيتحدد وفقا للموقف الذي سيتخذه
المرشح الثالث او الذي حل بالمرتبه
الثالثه سنان اوغان ويمتلك نسبه تتجاوز
الخمسه بالمئه كيف سيحدد وجه ناخبيه هو
سيكون العامل الاساسي في تحديد رئيس
الجمهوريه تركيا المقبل
نعم طيب ارجو ان تبقى معنا دكتور باسل اذا
مشاهدينا نحن معكم في هذه الساعه الحاسمه
طبعا الارقام تتغير
رغم ذلك انصار اردوغان يستمرون في
الاحتفال عوده الى غزي عنتاب عبد القادر
خربوش المعارضه التركيه تقول انه غدا
سيستفيق الاتراك على كمال كلجدار اوغلو
رئيسا
طيب مره اخرى ليس معنا عبد القادر دكتور
مهند حافظ اذا اعود اليك المعارضه التركيه
اذا تقول انه الاتراك غدا سيستفقون على
كمال كالجدار اولو رئيسا ما رايك
حتى ان منصوريه واش قال حسب مواقع تركيا
ان
كماك يحوز على 47% فاصله وانا رئيس
اردوغان وصل الى 45 بالمئه وبالتالي هذه
التصريحات وراها ما وراءها يعني لماذا
يصرح عمده اسطنبول وعمده انقره بهذه
التصريحات الان الان نحن نتحدث رئيس
الهيئه العليا للانتخابات يقوم المنصور
يافاش برايك يتحدث من فراغ يعني هو مسؤول
يعني هو شخصيه يعني لها اعتبارها يعني هل
معقول ان يتحدث من فراقي من فراغ يعطي
ارقام غير دقيقه
وهنا العتب الكبير هذه الارقام
مقدسه لدى المواطن التركي لا يمكن ان
تصريح بها الا من قبل الهيئه العليا
للانتخابات للرئيس اردوغان صلاحيه في ان
يتكلم بها او يصرح بها ولا اي رئيس حزب
ولا اي عمده ولا ايا كان فقط وفقط الدستور
وقانون الانتخابات ينص على ان الهيئه
العليا الانتخابات هي المخوله الجهه
المخوله الوحيده لهذه الارقام وتصريح بها
وبالتالي هذه الارقام المقدسه والحديث
عنها والتلاعب بها
والحديث بخلاف ما تقوله الهيئه للانتخابات
هذا يدل ربما على تخوف منهم بان الرئيس
اردوغان قد يفوز بالرئاسه وبالتالي سوف
يقولون ها نحن لدينا ارقام مختلفه
واصبحت هناك بعض التزويرات وبعض الضغوطات
وبعد التفاصيل يعني هم يستبقون الاحداث
ربما خشيه من امور ما واذا لم تكن الامور
جاء تاتي لصالح الرئيس اردوغان فيقول قلنا
لكم منذ البدايه ان الارقام التي لدينا هي
صحيحه وعندنا غير صحيحه وان الارقام
الرسميه غير صحيحه هذا طبعا مباشر غير
مباشر يعني اذا لم يحصل كلا المرشحين
بالفعل على خمسين اكثر من خمسين بالمئه
سنذهب الى جوله اعاده ماذا تتوقع لو ذهبنا
بالفعل الى جوله اعاده في الانتخابات
التركيه
بالنظر الى اصوات القوميين
الاكراد والذين ينطون تحت حزب الجيد ربما
سوف ترجح هذه الاصوات ليست بالقليله
بالاساس
ببعيد اصلا عن
النجاح الخمسين وزياده وبالتالي هذه
الاصوات سوف تذهب بطريقه اخرى الى الرئيس
اردوغان وفي الجوله الثانيه الامور سوف
تكون اكثر صعوبه على مرشح المعارضه كما
اكيد نعم طيب اذا ارجو ان تبقى معنا
الدكتور مهند دكتور باسل اعود اليك كذلك
فيما يتعلق
لاسالك عن حجم المشاركه القياسي في هذه
الانتخابات صحيح الان هناك حرب ارقام ما
بين الحزب الحاكم والمعارضه ولكن الشيء
الاكيد والثابت انه الاتراك ذهبوا بكثافه
للتصويت في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه الى ما يرجع هذا الاقبال
برايك
نعم هذه الانتخابات لها رمزيه كبرى اولا
هي تتزامن مع مرور 100 عام على تاسيس
الجمهوريه التركيه وثانيا حاله الاستقطاب
التي شهدناها منذ عده اشهر
وثالثا التحالف الذي شكلته المعارضه والذي
نظر اليه كتحالف عابر للاجالوجيه الا ان
الشيء الوحيد الذي جمعهم هو موضوع تغيير
نظام السياسي وازاحه الرئيس الحالي رجب
طيب اردوغان
وايضا قد يعني تكون هناك عوامل اخرى
اجتمعت في هذه الانتخابات بالاضافه طبعا
للعامل الايديولوجي وهو قد يكون في هذه
الانتخابات ليس اساسيا كما جرت العاده اذا
ما نظرنا طبعا لتحالف المعارضه فهو يعطيهم
نقط ايجابيه ومن ناحيه اخرى نقاط سلبيه
يعني شاهدنا كيف كان هناك تصريحات او
تغريدات سواء لعلي بابا جان وزير اقتصاد
سابق واحمد داوود كيف انه من الصعب عليهم
اقناع
اقاربهم بالتصويت لكمال كريستار اوغلو وهم
طوال حياتهم ينظرون اليه كخصم
دكتور باسل ارجو ان تبقى معنا مشاهدينا
تراجع اخر لاردوغان الان
49.67% لاردوغان مقابل 44.58 لكل بعد فرزه
92.98 يعني قرابه 93% من فرز الاصوات
اردوغان يصبح عند تسعه واربعين فاصل 67%
نقلا عن تي ار تي خبر طبعا ونقلا عن وكاله
الاناضول التركيه اذن طوال هذه الساعه
مشاهدينا كل ما يتقدم فرز الاصوات صحيح
ليس تراجعا كبيرا ولكن طبعا هو
يؤكد مره اخرى نقترب كل مره من سيناريو
جوله الاعاده الزميله اذا الان راويه
القاسم تتابع معكم هذه الارقام اذن راويه
هي ساعات حاسمه ربما تحصل فيها مفاجاه
صحيح والان نتائج الفرز هي الاثنين وتسعين
بالمئه يعني
في اجماع بانه سنذهب الى جوله اعاده لهذا
الانتخابات نتابع معك تفضل
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات